-Oh, gosh!
-So happy to be here!
-I'm so happy
that you're on the show.
You're so much fun.
-It's baby's first "Fallon."
It's your first time
on "Fallon."
I love you're here.
-Yes, thank you for having me.
-Come back.
First of many, hopefully.
You got to do something
very, very cool the other night,
by the way.
-I did.
-And you -- you got to announce
the biggest award of the night
at the American Music Awards.
-Mm-hmm.
And that award went to...
-BTS.
-That's right.
-Yes, it did.
-I mean --
-Deservingly so.
Come on, now.
-The fans went nuts on Twitter.
They go, "Literally me when BTS
won Artist of the Year."
-That is an involuntary,
instinctive reaction.
Look at that.
It looks like I won.
-Did you -- I know.
[ Laughter ]
It looks like you won, yeah.
-Yes.
-Did you fan out?
Are you --
Are you part of the Army?
-That's a little acting there.
I'm acting like
I'm in total shock but I'm --
of course,
they were going to win.
They're brilliant.
-Yeah.
-Such beast performers, yeah.
-Did you get to meet them
backstage?
-I did. I did this, like,
little, like --
"Oh, my gosh, kings, kings.
I'm in the presence of royalty,"
and they all bowed at me,
and I just felt their
gust of wind, just --
[ Laughter ]
-When they all bow at the same
time, you get a gust of wind.
They form --
They're like Voltron.
-Uh-huh.
-They form one giant robot.
Yeah.
-It's everything I want.
I was fed.
-They're unbelievable.
They crushed it
at the AMAs, too.
-They're perfectionists.
-Yeah.
-They can sing, they can dance.
-They can do it all.
-They look good,
they know what to do.
-They're, like, popping,
locking, everything, yeah.
-They're a star.
But I mean -- can --
Can we hear your story?
How did --
Well, how did you become a star?
-Yes. Oh, my goodness.
Okay, so --
-Where did you start?
-It started in Houston, Texas.
Born and raised, H-Town.
[ Cheers ]
Come on H-Town! Represent!
That's right, H-Town,
hold it down, barbecue.
What's up?
[ Laughter ]
Then, I had a second birth
on Vine.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There we go.
Yep, yep, yep.
-Some people on Vine.
-It's dead now, but, you know...
-Yeah.
Vine -- the Vine died.
-Yeah, Vine died.
Pour one out, every time.
-Yeah.
-But I accidently
tripped into the industry.
So I started at 17 years old
in high school,
and I was just doing it for,
like, my small circle,
my group chat,
that used to be, like,
your Twitter, right?
-Yeah.
-And, well, that circle
just grew and grew and grew,
and now I have this audience
that I'm so grateful to have.
-Let's talk about
"Liza On Demand." This is...
[ Applause ]
-Yeah.
Thank you.
-...the third season.
And it's the final season.
-It is the final --
third and final season.
-That's a little bittersweet.
-I'll bring you into the world.
Here, put 30 seconds
on the clock.
Here's the elevator pitch.
-Mm.
-All right, here we go.
So basically --
[ Drum roll ]
That's right, give it a roll.
[ Laughter ]
Basically, this is the world
of the gig economy, right?
We're all living in a time
of assisted living.
All of us have our own
personal assistants, right?
You hire somebody to drive you
somewhere to go.
You hire somebody
to get you food
to the place
that you don't want to go.
And you hire somebody to cry
at your funeral
because there aren't enough
people to cry there.
It's a real thing.
It's a job, and, yes,
I am available to do it
if you need it.
[ Laughter ]
Season three is just, like,
the wrap-up.
She is embracing herself
as this independent woman
who is employing herself
on her phone.
-Good.
-And it kind of
parallels my real life
of getting started.
My career's
in the palm of my hand.
So, anything's possible
nowadays. Let's go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You did a pretty awesome job
of that.
-45 seconds.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Liza Koshy in season 3
of "Liza On Demand."
Take a look at this.
-Who's gonna do
Self-Care Sunday with me?
-I can't do my own eyebrows.
Give me those.
[ All mumbling ]
[ Muffled laughing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh my gosh.
-Come on, buddy.
That's fun right there.
-There's nothing like
a quarter-life crisis
around a campfire.
-I love that.
Liza Koshy, everybody.
Check out the new season
of "Liza On Demand"
on her YouTube channel.